Rob here with a gs news update it's been
a roller coaster of a year for Nintendo
but as Mario Kart 8 helps get the Wii U
back in the race
the company has re-elected Satoru Iwata
as president
yada has been president since 2002 and
was reinstated to the board along with
nine others including legendary Nintendo
game designer Shigeru Miyamoto after
Nintendo suffered its third straight
year of financial loss eeeyah wada
apologized for the poor performance but
said that doesn't mean he intends to
leave the company since then we you
sales have been on the rise Mario Kart 8
launched in May and Nintendo said this
helped Wii U sales increase by a
significant margin the NPD numbers will
give us a better picture of Mario Kart
8's influence when they are released in
a couple of weeks at e3 we got a better
look at Super Smash Bros which is coming
to both Wii U and 3ds as well as our
first glimpse at the new Legend of Zelda
which could sell me a system if it was
the only game on it
many people were hoping for new
leadership at Nintendo while others
appreciate Nintendo sticking to his guns
and doing what it knows best leave your
opinions in the comments see you next
time
you